perché sono giocatori e sull'umanità e
vitale e oggi faremo una nuova challenge
con la ruota grandissima ricchezza e gli
origami so chi me lo avete visti gli
altri video con gli origami sono andate
a vederli dopo questo video li potete
trovare il ridicolo fra i triangolini
silicone profumati in cui potete creare
tantissime cose sono il nuovo trend del
momento non sia la casta non la
challenge praticamente nella ruota
andiamo un easter ingorde abbiamo
oggetti animali cibo ion in tali sedi
giuste e l'altro una cosa che gireremo
la ruota e faremo una delle creazioni
che ci capita e voi dovrete votare come
sempre qua nel sondaggio se dicesse più
la mia creazione
passi pure video fino alla fine per
vedere tutte le creazioni alla fine del
video farò vedere anche le vostre
creazioni che mi avete inviato suite
grandi chef saluteremo e poi faremo
rivedere tutte le nostre creazioni
o'regan schemi un fatto in questi giorni
negli altri video così potrete votare
qual è la più belle assoluto del demodè
e il vincitore tra tutte le creazioni
metodi ricavati allacciate un bel mac
per altre challenge con la ruota e
intimità e degli occhi
inizia io vitale al lavoro fatto dai
carteggi hmv abbiano mai filato piano
prettamente oggetti si è capitato oggi e
quelli recenti portapenne immobile
portamatite non sa puoi inventarti in
quello che adesso io faccio l'aereo
calamitare costruirà il suo progetto
poi nonostante la finito dire l'ho io e
così però quello che mi capita perché
tremonti non posso entrare il progetto
fine anno qui dovrete votare il previsto
e l'oggetto o quello che capiterà a me è
stato scelto di fare il portapenne e con
cui lo vedete ho già preparato tutti i
triangoli sono deciso di cambiare il uno
dei colori del disegno mettendo del rosa
chiaro come per fare un pochino che
unicorn ott
[Musica]
eccolo qua non riuscivo mai a competere
con questa creazione anche di signore
che superman
ora proviamo proviamo servizi doverle
center 3 fede o per sé è bellissimo
fantastico da portare a scuola o da
tenere in cameretta è il più profumo
tantissimo quindi profumerà la vostra
cameretta nord è un fantastico questo
momento sulla scrivania bellissimo
bellissimo e profumatissimo mele proprio
noi e di queste credenti io io tu ti
devi scontrare contro chiesto di parlare
ti ho mai a vincere diamo cosa capita a
me scegliere qualsiasi ricordati che
dovrà competere col mio padre
un fiore allora ho deciso di prendere
ispirazione dal girasole però farò una
mia versione un po più colorata pronti
via
[Musica]
il cuore mio fiore finito a tantissimi
colori dei petali e non so se si vede
macelli campo verde con la foglia e
caldissimo vi piace un sacco
io ero mettiamo lì a confronto la porta
per fiorai ore votate nel sondaggio
quale vi piace di più e più volte lo
vogliono tutti e due tantissimo c'è un
buonissimo profumo del successo
l'uomo quindi votate chi inizia questo
turno vanità o vitale secondo vediamo
che ci capiterà questa volta va in giro
animali granchio chiesto di tesero
voglio fare non so come te lo sei
[Musica]
ho deciso di cambiare colore di farlo
arancione perché il trucchetto è più
arancione e bianco
[Musica]
che carino quegli occhietti davanti non
è chiaro e profuma ma non profuma di
mesi profumo di vaniglia e nocciola
prendere troppo carino anche le che le
domande gli occhietti bellissimo vi
capiterà competere coi gran fetta di
ridge rizzi era più piccolo
si no che cosa può competere nel mio
franchetto cose se non lo trovo che
giusto e di quella che sceglieranno
qualcosa qualsiasi che non sia nei nei
main stream o acquisiti e qualcuno del
listino la mia umanità
ti faccio fare in pace ma semplici pensa
che contesta chi non vorrebbe il
braccialetto principe beh allora ecco
qua il braccialetto da principessa ho
deciso di sostituire il verde con il
viola e frattini subito
[Musica]
ecco qua il mio bracciale da principessa
un video bellissimo e colorito stupendi
si sono i mini castelli dal principe
contro castelli 4 castelli contro
pensionato che con quell'infrazione la
principessa si è bellissimo
i castelli qua è così che sono un sacco
il colore rosa chiaro viola e
fucsia e profumo tantissimo anche questo
quindi bracciali da principessa contro
grangetto rosso ragione chi votate
questa volta sono tutti e due stupendi
votate nel sondaggio chi vince quest'ora
allora i vostri momento di farvi vedere
le vostre creazioni è salutarvi inizia
subito la prima creazione un bellissimo
fiore fatto da melli fra bellissimo tra
l'altro messo un sacco di petali che
calino giovanili bellissimo prossimo è
un cubetto fatto da mike ha deciso che
li di cambiare un pò i quali questo che
la mano celeste e bianco arancione nero
e fucsia e bellissimo bravissimo vari
calcio ma due di adattate a che ci manda
una sorta di spetta di anguria però
arcobaleno multicolor di cambiare il
colore bellissimo e bravissimo
bravissimo marotta la prima creazione da
nicole ha fatto un fiore bellissimo
giallo e viola è bellissimo gioco
un'altra creazione da anastasia
bellissimo fiorellino roma creazioni da
giada bardelli e ha fatto innanzitutto
gli origami e vestito benissimo stupendo
e poi ha fatto il fiore bravissimo
agiata ciao ciao ci manda sempre la
tartarughina e l'ha fatta a verde e
selene ha fatto due mesi una verde
cinese e una rosa creazione da chiara è
affatto la genziana lo stesso in fiore è
affatto la tartaruga ha aggiornato i
colori rosa e verde teca risi bravissima
chiaro bacioni ciò che era la creazione
da rebecca cindy ha fatto la terza
fermata verde scuro e verde chiaro è
uscito benissimo bravissimo rebecca
hudson john beck grado
allora fatelo nostri creatori mentre
questa create e ora facciamo vedere
tutte le nostre creazioni con gli
origami hicks così potete votare quella
che mi piace piede tante e delle già un
vincitore creazioni in questa fila
abbiamo i nostri animaletti in questo
caso sono tutti i mari lì perché abbiamo
il granchietto che troppo caldo
poi abbiamo la tartaruga di mare quella
che abbiamo fatto nella challenge tre
colori infatti molto colorata
poi abbiamo la tartare via di mare tutta
di un colore cioè da sé scuro e verdi
chiaro e poi la per parte di mario brusa
le celeste che carina poi nella seconda
fila ma andiamo in fiore che abbiamo
fatto primo multicolor poi un altro
grillino che perino poi qua abbiamo una
sorta di fiore senza cavo però che si
appoggia tutti profumatissimi copie
munini fiore rosa poi abbiamo un
braccialetto un altro braccialetto che
tu il mio braccialetto principesco che è
stupendo azione qua abbiamo la frutta
abbiamo le banane mano ride
poi abbiamo l'ananas e quella piccolina
questa poi abbiamo l'ananas gigante che
ama la bellissima e poi abbiamo il cup
cakes afragola cupcake lee curtis
unicorno e per finire abbiamo il
portapenne che stupendo anche questo
allora crisi sono tutte le nostre ferite
che gli hooligans siamo super conte dice
siamo divertiti un sacco a farli e farli
è veramente il rilassante perché team i
tiri li fai piano piano in che c'è
questo profumo fantastic parlo senza che
questo rumore sta chiamando qualcuno
qualcuno del vitalità qual è il tuo
aiuto ricami preferito adesso lo diciamo
a tutti quali sono i lastroni calibro di
john voi scrivete nei commenti
qual è il vincitore secondo voi e anche
noi dobbiamo scegliere un vincitore
io andavo per forza a scegliere uno mia
o indecisa secondo me è vitale è stato
bravissimo ragioni deciso tra il
portapenne che lo perde tra l'altro con
questo disegno al centro che si ripete è
bellissimo vero mi chiedo perché troppo
con questi occhietti festeggeremo penso
che scelgo beh anche l'anas gigante
finissima però scelto il portapenne
perché è veramente bellissimo con questo
disegno fa quindi io son porta bene come
e dove avrebbe soltanto e detrazioni che
hai fatto tu lì anzi lo bello questo
particolare tutto colorato dei
granchietti ovviamente
piaciuta tantisssimo e la tartarughina
anche la tartarughina questa verde mi
piace tanto e quale sei i canoni gettare
ci fa piacere granchietto perché ha un
fratello troppo dire di no grazie
e voi vi svegliate visitare impariamo
che potete trovare theory galaxy in
edicola è legato al magazine sono
fantastici e profumatissimi sono passati
tantissimi colori lasciato per la
inseguitore delle altre challenger ora
vi lasciamo qua quattro cartellini
quindi cara per vedere i nostri altri
video cliccate su quella che preferiva
anche perché